just in case we encounter any more
trolls who want us to figure out what
types of money they have in their
pockets we have devised an exercise for
you to practice with and this is to
solve systems of equations visually so
they say right over here graph this
system of equations and solve and they
give us two equations this first one in
blue y is equal to seven fifths x minus
five and then this one in green y is
equal to three fifths x minus one
so let's graph each of these and we'll
do it in the corresponding color so
first let's graph this first equation so
the first thing i see is that its
y-intercept is negative five or another
way to think about it when x is equal to
zero
y is going to be negative 5. so let's
try this out so when x is equal to 0
y is going to be equal to negative 5. so
that makes sense
and then we see its slope is 7 fifths
this was conveniently placed in slope
intercept form for us so it's rise over
run so for every time it moves five to
the right it's going to move seven up so
if it moves one two three four five to
the right it's going to move seven up
one two three four five six seven so
it'll get right
over there another way you could have
done it is you could have just tested
out some values you could have said oh
when x is equal to zero y is equal to
negative five when x is equal to five
when x is equal to five seven fifths
times five is seven minus five is two so
i think we've properly graphed this top
one let's try this bottom one right over
here
so we have
negative when x is equal to zero y is
equal to negative one so when x is equal
to zero y is equal to negative one and
the slope is three fifths so if we move
over five to the right if we move over
five to the right we will move up three
so we will go right over there and it
looks like they intersect right at that
point right at the point x is equal to
five y is equal to two so we'll type in
x is equal to five
y is equal to 2 and you can even verify
by substituting those values into both
equations to show that it does satisfy
both constraints so let's check our
answer
and it worked